sometimes we have to wonder and
speculate about how someone comes to
hold radical beliefs or becomes
motivated to commit violence in the real
world and sometimes the people who do
those things will actually tell us and
we've actually figured that out with the
mag a bomber the mag a bomber is this 57
year old Florida man who sent all those
pipe bombs through the mail to Democrats
and was ultimately caught you'll
remember maybe images of his van covered
in right-wing messaging and stickers and
he has told us that he was radicalized
by Fox News along with other right-wing
media he pled guilty to 65 counts back
in March and there's a whole bunch of
court documents that have now been
released that are extremely insightful
as well as disturbing to be quite honest
with you and his attorney actually says
his attorney is safe through these court
documents that the magg a bomber quote
found light in Donald Trump that he
watched Fox News quote religiously and
specifically he was watching Fox &
Friends in the morning and Hannity in
the evening check out this quote from
the court documents his infatuation with
the president began as something
personal not political when he was most
down mr saye cruel ID on self-help books
on tape to keep going Donald Trump's
books on success and business were his
favorites mr. seoc was an ardent Trump
fan and when Trump announced he was
running for president mr. seoc
enthusiastically supported him he began
watching Fox News religiously at the gym
planning his morning workout to coincide
with Fox & Friends and his evenings to
dovetail with Hannity he became obsessed
with quote attacks from those he
perceived as Trump's enemies and the
court documents go on to outline that he
was not only radicalized through
right-wing media and the Internet but he
used that same Internet to also learn to
build the pipe bombs that he ultimately
ended up sending to Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama George Soros and a number
of other people whose names escape me
so the real important takeaway here is
that the media stuff is not a game once
you understand the concept of stochastic
terrorism which I've talked about enough
this week I'm not going to redefine it
but google it or check out some of my
stories from our
this week about it when you understand
the sort of fundamental vulnerability of
so many people you really should have a
sense of responsibility for everything
that you say in a public forum in media
on TV or in a YouTube channel and the
radicalizing impact of extremist media
is just massive and if you what listen
to live calls on our show we've received
a lot of calls from people who call in
and say they were radicalized by you
know they will sometimes say it was Alex
Jones or Infowars stefan molyneux
Breitbart
could be Fox News could be the blaze
there are less well-known ones as well I
can't think of all of them offhand the
point is this is not an exception to the
rule the combination of extremely
outrageous content meant to foment anger
rather than activism that benefits the
majority of people or that improve
society this anger porn that is so
popular among particularly right-wing
media combined with the echo-chamber
algorithmic self-perpetuating loops that
people can get into on YouTube or in
other places online Twitter Facebook etc
this is meant to give people more and
more of what resonates with them the
most and what we have to understand is
that for many people that self that
constant feedback loop is going to leave
them to take real-world action this is
not me saying you know Facebook's
algorithm is a terroristic I'm not
saying that I'm not going that far I'm
not saying that when Glenn Beck rants
and raves about the tides foundation and
someone goes and tries to shoot up the
tides foundation that now Glenn Beck is
specifically guilty of a crime what I'm
saying is if we want to have an adult
conversation that goes beyond the letter
of the law we have to understand the
responsibility that we have anytime
people are consuming messages that we
put out into the media where you don't
know everyone that's hearing it right
when you're at a dinner party and you're
talking to six people you know who is
receiving your message and you can in
real time sort of gauge their reaction
and most people would naturally kind of
tailor their speech to make sense for
the people that they're speaking to when
I do a segment and five hundred thousand
people watch it on YouTube
I don't know the mental state of
everybody who's watching I don't know
the way that everybody is hearing what
I'm saying and I take that as a very
serious responsibility to try to speak
in a way that it is responsible for to
use that same word that trite type of
responsibility is something that seems
completely missing from a lot of these
narratives that are crafted by
right-wing media and these court
documents tell us exactly how it works
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15 minute audio book you get all the
most important information and insights
from each book but you can soak up the
entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a David Pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n